- So wait Jurnee.
One of your first movies was "Eve's Bayou"
which turns 25 this year.
That's incredible.
How do you feel things have progressed
for black women in film,
in front of the camera
and behind?
Because you're working in both.
Look at you both.
You both,
they both looked over.
- You Know,
- Yeah, yeah.
- You want me to take over?
- Oh my God.
You don't really wanna
answer the question.
- I think the truth of the matter is,
is like,
I'm encouraged because
there's so many more
of us behind the camera.
Executive producing,
producing,
writing,
directing,
ushering forward stories
that aren't typically,
you know,
pushed forward by the cis white male.
Right?
- Yeah.
- You know?
And so I'm excited because there's
so many voices
to be excited about.
However,
we have so far to go,
you know?
- So far.
- Yeah.
We're like step one on
like a thousand.
But we're getting there,
we're getting there.
And there's a lot of people who
are part of the solution
and creating the change we wanna be.
And we're all
we all have production companies.
And we're all just trying
to you know?
Employ more
you know,
amazing talented people
who have been underserved
in our community.
- Yeah.
And I think so many people
are just not waiting
for an invitation to sit at the table.
They're just like,
we're gonna build our table
- Oh, we built
our own table in our own house
and our own land.
Yeah
- Amen.
Yeah.
- It's an interesting topic
in general,
just for women as well,
because I literally just did
this thing with Dolly
who just released "Nine to Five."
And it's interesting cause there's
a whole documentary about it.
How it's still applicable,
you know?
The message is still applicable.
And it was so many years ago.
I wanna get to a place where we don't have
to have the conversation.
You know?
That would be beautiful.
- So people don't lose it over
a black mermaid.
- Yeah.
Someone lost it over a black mermaid?
- A lot of people.
They're like,
"she's black."
I'm like "she's a fish."
(crowd laughs)
- She's a fish.
- Oh my God,
you know her friend
is a talking crab.
(crowd claps)
- Wait.
- The authenticity thing is.
- I didn't know this.
But wait,
like mermaids aren't real.
- They're not real.
Fish don't talk.
- Like how dare you?
How dare you suppose?
- Middle Earth isn't real either.
People have very
strong feelings.
- Middle Earth
isn't real.